yes it's the segment backed by no demand
whatsoever
it's where we read a bunch of jokes that
didn't make it into the show this week
and like any leftovers some are good
some bad some in between but you never
know until you dig in and then throw up
that was all as always this is my first
time reading these jokes so if they
really suck i'll just fire someone later
here we go
this week rhode island state senator
tierra mack posted a video of herself
upside down twerking on a public beach
critics call it the scariest upside down
captured on film since stranger things
i don't get it
a survey found that chick-fil-a is
america's favorite restaurant for the
eighth year in a row
in related news driving democrats
absolutely mad chick-fil-a has also been
appointed to the supreme court
right president biden has hit a new
approval low according to a new poll
white house staffers say the president
will be very upset once they remind him
that he is joe biden
that was good
keep that one white house communications
director kate bennyfield departing the
white house later this month she said
she wants to spend more time with her
cnn contributor job
that was funny
a recent study found that neighborhoods
with more dogs have less crime
if that's true the set of the view has
to be the safest place in america
care
no that's why it wasn't in the show
deborah messing reportedly had a tense
call with a white house staff recently
complaining how the president has been
acting which is the same complaint fans
have about everything she's ever been in
that was good
she also complained her support for the
president had been a waste of time
unfortunately joe was on a separate
two-hour call about renewing air force
one's extended service warranty
[Laughter]
crosby still nash and young quietly
returned to spotify five months ago
after leaving due to the platform
support for joe rogan they had looked
for a service more appropriate for their
audience but couldn't find one that
streamed eight tracks
band member david crosby condemned rogan
for spreading health disinformation and
who better to trust than a man who did
so much cocaine his septum was wider
than the lincoln tunnel
a new poll claims gavin newsom is a
stronger presidential candidate than
kamala harris the survey revealed voters
prefer newsom because they think it's
finally time we have a female president
wow
that is vicious
i don't know
the popeye comic strip is getting a
makeover to include more characters who
aren't heterosexual
now wimpy previously known for his love
of hamburgers has pivoted his preferred
food choice to foot long wieners
i think
i think a 10 year old wrote that one
getting those kids involved in the
writing process last weekend nasa
administrators claimed that china might
take over the moon as part of a new
military program meanwhile north korea
launched its own moon mission consisting
of 300 balloons binoculars and a lawn
chair
and finally god i've never been happier
to hear those words
you know
nope not with you on this one
a 19-foot granite monument known as the
georgia guidestones was destroyed in an
explosion this week officials say it's
the worst bombing in georgia since
michael loftus performed in atlanta
we've come full circle
don't go away we'll be right back hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else